toronto appears as the backdrop for
plenty of movies and tv shows but
oftentimes it's disguised as an american
city this time however it finally gets
its chance to shine with the cn tower
not needing to be cut in post this was
my chance to really put my hometown on
the map as the most multicultural city
in the world it has plenty of stories to
tell and we're giving you a peek at the
most popular one being told right now
turning red
domi she was a huge anime lover growing
up we liked sailor moon we liked anime
the four anime influences for turning
red include sailor moon ronmo one half
fruits basket and inuyasha what a lot of
these animes have in common is the theme
of transformation the real challenge the
creative team was met with was combining
2d anime with pixar's standard 3d films
domi she said of the experience i've
always loved how colorful and expressive
anime is how they really exaggerate
facial features and character reactions
and you really feel what the characters
are feeling at any given moment this is
reflected in turning red with those
sudden twinkling eyes and those big
honking bean mouths that we love so much
uh mei
why are you staring at carter murphy
mayhew the inspiration for the big pink
cloud that accompanied may's
transformation was inspired by ronma one
half the creative team was going for a
dreamy teenage vaporwave fever dream
vibe so we added a lot of pastel blues
and raspberry pinks the movie soft color
palette had an influence on the overall
look and feel of every other element in
the film we definitely have a lot of
expertise on the movie about uh being 13
year old girls whoever the lead is in a
movie has some character trait of the
writer a lot of the inspiration for the
main character of course came from
writer director domi shi
mei's semi based off of myself and my
ride-or-die dork squad the spunkiness
and the loudness are just two of the
character traits domi likened mei to
herself with and some moments even come
directly from experiences she had
growing up in toronto like this slightly
embarrassing one drawing boys and mermen
in my sketchbook secretly under my bed
did anybody else draw exactly like may
does in the movie like if you dug out
some of your old school work with the
margins all doodled on you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference it makes
domi cringe thinking back on the memory
but she's proud of the inclusion in the
film that and the inclusion of four town
simulating her favorite boy bands but it
isn't all about nostalgia for domi it's
also about being the daughter of
immigrants and being the only child of
my overprotective mom and dad
imagine being that one woman in a boy
band billy eilish and phineas o'connell
were stoked to join the turning red team
and write three boy band songs in the
style of nsync it's literally been the
most fun we've had writing lindsay
collins the film's producer said when we
first started talking about billy eilish
and phineas back before they'd won a
billion grammys we could see then how
they had their finger on the pulse we
were big fans when we got approached
about this project we left at the
opportunity honestly who wouldn't leap
at that
true it was very exciting quite
literally changing the face of film and
tv toronto is the most multicultural
city in the world did we mention that
and the team of turning red wanted that
reflected a technology was developed
that would in any frame of a scene
analyze what the representation was on
the screen this was a very helpful tool
because in wide shots they may get the
representation they aim to achieve but
different angles may skew the results
all this kind of diversity that you've
created is it is it actually making it
on the screen in the way that we were
intending not only was the team doing
their best at being culturally diverse
but including details like wheelchair
ramps and insulin patches that's so
awesome that people can see themselves
hey girlfriends what is up
you would never be able to guess that
the actors weren't in the same room or
state it was thanks to domi she knowing
the story she wanted to tell inside out
helping assist the actors to get the
reads she wanted for her movie as the
two lead actors who played mae and her
mom did not record together rosalie and
i both recorded at our separately it at
our own homes
and then they recorded separately at
pixar and los angeles locations later on
the two never actually officially met in
person until the press tour i've been
working on this film for four years and
to finally be here at the world premiere
is surreal sometimes lines get cut and
sometimes great lines get cut we're just
a little bit sad to hear this quirky
canadian relevant pickup line was
replaced are you a beaver cause damn
the line was cut and replaced with a new
even dorkier geometry triangle joke
which like yes it was also great it's
just too bad there wasn't space for both
oh about the hustle am i right
one day there will be a disney
documentary on these guys
while recording for the four town boy
band booth sessions the guys were
goofing around and imitating each other
and it was just a lot of fun for them
insync was the main inspiration for the
music the tracks are written so well
with really tight harmonies that
complement each of their ranges topher
went on to say the songs are absolute
bops there's some fun party tunes um
there's some radio hit and then there's
like also a ballad a really like nice
balance so voice acting sessions that
were actually in a studio are
you
serious
while a lot of the voice acting was
recorded from home there was still
definitely lots of studio time down the
line there's just so many ways to say
something
that like so many different tones of
your voice oh my gosh that's like the
best thing ever we are curious to know
what they had in mind with the gangsters
there were eight alternative plots to
turning red an earlier concept contained
far more family and was set at a funeral
there was another screwball comedy
version that had chinese gangsters in it
and then there was a version presumably
later version where the size of mei's
panda changed depending on her mood at
one point may was so big she could lift
a car and guaranteed there would have
been plenty of comedy about her size we
imagine like alice in wonderland this
idea wound up scrapped because it was
just too complicated i never asked for
anything my whole life i've been her
perfect little maymay red and white and
fluffy all over the reason behind the
red panda is pretty beautiful then also
it's like red and white like chinese but
also like the colors of the canadian
flag domi she found that it felt like
the perfect animal to tell this story
about this chinese-canadian teenage girl
this will never happen again
firsts are still being accomplished
every day this was pixar's first movie
done solely by a female director and it
had an all-female leadership team when
you're telling a story about a 13 year
old girl going through magical puberty
that's most definitely the right route
to go danielle feinberg has had many
experiences where she was one of few
women in the room she is the visual
effects supervisor on the film first
woman in 20 years at pixar to have that
job chunky cute is the new aesthetic and
it's here to stay we definitely embraced
her chunky cute the creative team was
proud to include and celebrate small
details that often get left out of
animation including thick ankles round
cheeks moles a dip in the lip and patchy
eyebrows all of these inclusions led to
a truly heartfelt story obviously the
most magical experience in my entire
life are you a beaver cause damn is a
classic one of us here at the things has
definitely used that pickup line to land
a date we won't say who truly though you
would be hard-pressed to find another
movie that hits that nostalgia feel so
close who was your favorite boy band
growing up let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things